in this video we'll talk about
clostridium perfringens
this is a rod-shaped bacteria of the
genus clostridium
they are gram-positive
anaerobic spore-forming pathogenic
bacterium quite a lot of terms in this
video we'll look at all these aspects of
clostridium perfringens and look at from
the clinical point of view
cdc estimates that these bacteria can
cause roughly 1 million illnesses in
united states every year
and this particular bacteria is a cause
of food poisoning
other than that clostridium perfringens
is well known to cause gas gangrene
gas gangrene is a notorious pathological
symptom
let's talk about it in details
but what makes
clostridium perfringens very dangerous
is the spore forming ability
it can form endospores which are
resistant to extreme conditions of
starvation acidity temperature or
desiccation
simply they can survive the harsh
environment
now gas gangrene is a bacterial disease
caused by clostridium perfringens and
it's a deadly disease if untreated
the injured tissue produces foul
smelling gas and that's why the name is
gas gangrene
so in this case the symptoms are
swelling necrosis of that local region
numbness on the affected region fever
skin gets decolorized
there is foul smelling discharge from
the lesion in the skin and then that is
why the name was
gas gangrene
ultimately there are distinctive black
bubble lesions on the skin around the
affected area
now this gas gangrene leads to
clostridial myonecrosis
myonecrosis means
necrosis of the muscle tissues
and it and it is due to the exotoxins
produced by this particular bacteria
it leads to damage in the muscle tissue
and this is very specific to muscle
tissue itself
now this bacteria is an opportunistic
pathogen in general that means they can
enter the body through the
wherever there is a breakage in the skin
now gangrenous infection was soil borne
because this particular bacteria was
found in the soil and this was most
common during uh the second world war
and it is present in combat soldiers
now spores of clostridium perfringens
can germinate in open wounds and can
produce cytotoxic
substances
and the cytotoxic substance include
alpha toxin and theta toxin
the alpha toxin is associated with
hemolysis that means rupturing the red
blood cells and the theta toxin can
damage the blood vessel wall
that leads to restriction in blood flow
now when there is less amount of blood
flow in the nearby tissue there are
cascades of event that can happen first
of all
there could be further restrictions in
the blood flow in the region then as
there is a restriction in blood flow
other cells such as neutrophil basophil
and these immune cells cannot come to
the target region and combat this kind
of pathogens that means they are holding
the immune system to invade these region
now the hemolytic activity of alpha
toxin
is produced in an anaerobic environment
which is essential for the proliferation
of these bacteria
so
anyway they grow in soil
and that is why they need an anaerobic
environment oxygen is actually harmful
for them they won't grow in oxygen
unlike any other anaerobic infection the
discharge of these infection is not at
all purulent that means pass filled
discharge is not found
instead the discharge is sweetly
portrayed and it's like
a kind of like a faint yellowish fluid
and this is very characteristic to gas
gangrene
the toxins can be carried from one
region of the body to the other region
of the body and this could have a long
range effect for example
this toxins can go to the kidney
which can cause renal problems
it can also cause shock renal failure
intravascular hemolysis and many other
symptoms
in short
if this particular toxin spreads over
the body it might have several systemic
effects
now as we have mentioned before
clostridium perfringens and some strain
of these clostridium perfringens can
cause food poisoning and that's a severe
form of food poisoning as these are like
spore forming bacteria they can even
stay in the cooked food
cdc estimates over 1 million food
poisoning cases in united states alone
so when the specimen is obtained from
any patient
generally you can do the grum staining
they would turn out to be gram positive
and they are rods so they can be easily
observed under the microscope
alternatively when cultured
anaerobically on blood agar
c perfringens produces a unique beta
hemolysis pattern
anyway this infection is a bacterial
infection so it is treatable
if this infection has not spread that
much
then doctor would prescribe proper
medications antibiotics which can combat
this infection but in case of extreme
situation there could be amputation of
specific digits for example amputation
of a portion of the leg
sometimes there is an exposure to hypo
hyperbaric oxygen therapy that means
these pathogens are not at all well
versed with oxygen actually oxygen is
harmful for them they are anaerobic
right that is why
in order to make these bacteria
uncomfortable hyperbaric oxygen
treatment is done
high doses of penicillin and doxycycline
should be administered to kill these
pathogens
that pretty much summarize this video we
looked at what is the infective
potential of c perfringens
we looked that gas gangrene can be
caused by c perfringens
we elaborated on the pathophysiology and
looked at that toxins that can be uh
causing the harmful effects in
gas gangrene lastly we looked at the lab
diagnosis of c perforations
in order to get more notes and flash
flashcards you can follow me on facebook
or instagram you can download all of
these flash cards which are super
informative useful for your preparation
all the links are provided in the
description you can support my channel
by clicking on the super thanks option
present in the bottom right corner of
each video you can contribute using
paytm paypal upi or internet banking
so thanks for watching all my social
media links and social media links for
nerd medic channel is pinned in the
description box you can connect to us at
any point of time feel free to connect
and please comment in the video whether
you are liking it or not see you in the
next video